[Music]
Adidas and Puma are two of the biggest
rivals and shoes but did you know that
their founders were two halves of a once
happy family business that turned into a
level of brother rage so intense it will
get the sneakerheads tongues of wagon
see what I did there in the 1930s the
Dassler brother sports shoe company in
Bavaria made the most kick-ass athletic
shoes in all the land the company even
gave Jesse Owens a pair of shoes to
compete in the 36 Olympics when Jesse
won the brothers shoes blew up but all
of that success was not good for their
relationship tensions flared some say
there was stealing Affairs resentment
and after World War 2 the brothers were
so out of step they eventually ended the
company in 1949 8 off or Adi Dassler
formed Adidas a play on his nickname
Rudolf Dassler started Puma because well
that name is awesome the brothers suit
each other many many times over the
years over all sorts of design and
trademark issues costing each other a
fortune in lawyers and suits their two
factories built in the same Bavarian
village of pets and Genaro to polarize
the community with local people picking
sides by picking shoes the brothers died
two years apart they are buried at
opposite ends of the village graveyard
proof that even in death they remained a
great bitter divide between them and so
it was for decades until 2009 employees
of Adidas and Puma in the village where
the two companies still have their
headquarters came together
and played a friendly soccer match and
started the process of healing decades
of em nity and began a new era of love
and shoes a knee Londonderry is famous
for being the first woman to bicycle
around the world but there's more to the
story and the story starts as most
things do in a dark bar there is no
possible way a woman could ride a
bicycle around the world can you imagine
a woman trying to do it in a skirt every
woman could do that I'm paid $10,000 I
anni Londonderry will take that wager
[Music]
when Annie took that wager he was losing
with confidence and charisma but here's
the thing
she had never even touched a bicycle in
the late 1800s bicycles were seen as
dangerous for women and very unfeminine
riding a bicycle was a revolutionary act
legend has it she cycled from Boston to
New York City to Paris riding her bike
one-footed after an injury to India
hunting Tigers with royalty Singapore
Hong Kong getting caught up in a war and
sustaining a gunshot wound to her
shoulder Nagasaki being interned in a
Japanese prison how did she get over
oceans don't worry about it San
Francisco Los Angeles Phoenix and all
the way back to Boston in exactly 15
months she did it the end well no that
was exactly true and you are I'm pewter
Zeitlin and Annie was my great grand
aunt okay so then what actually happened
she was full of tall tales even her name
Annie Londonderry wasn't real her real
name was Annie Cohen and kept Chesky
she even concocted the story of the
wager and she definitely was not shot
we're thrown into a prison during the
chinese-japanese war what about all that
other stuff like the leg injury
she didn't injure her leg how about
hunting for Tigers with royalty
that's false so with some true stuff and
some not so true stuff how do you view
her journey
although hers was a remarkable physical
achievement a real achievement was
becoming world-famous as a symbol of the
women's liberation movement the 1890s
Annie's sheer audacity and the way she
fought for herself for her own
adventures on her own terms was
remarkable for her time even if her
story was kinda sorta not totally
accurate
[Music]
it was spring 1967 LBJ was in the White
House the Vietnam War was in full swing
and the biggest musical act in America
was the month
[Music]
in that same spring a chance encounter
in New York City's Greenwich Village
would kick off one of the strangest and
most ill-fated
intersections of pop culture in history
[Music]
here's monkeys drummer Micky Dolenz
somebody said you got to come down and
see this incredible guitar player that
plays guitar with his teeth there was no
name attached nothing that no-name
guitar player was none other than rock
and roll legend in the making Jimi
Hendrix flash forward to June of that
year
it's the Monterey Pop Festival
[Applause]
and I'm sitting in the audience all of a
sudden out walks these three ratably
decorated characters and I just remember
going that's the guy that plays guitar
with his teeth and of course by then
they were the Jimi Hendrix Experience
Mickey was impressed everybody was blown
away and I told our producers you gotta
check this guy out
cuz we were looking for an opening act
and despite some fairly obvious
differences in musical style a deal was
struck
sure enough the opening act for the
Monkees was the Jimi Hendrix Experience
a new group Jimi Hendrix Experience
traveling with the Monkees and they
joined the Monkees concert tour so the
two acts hit the road
but as it turned out fans would come to
see the monkeys weren't quite sure what
to make of Jimi Hendrix he would go
onstage to open the act and he'd be
going later we want the monk it was kind
of embarrassing frankly and things
didn't get much better as the tour
continued and after only seven shows
Jimi had had enough I did hear the rumor
at one of the last shows he finally
flipped off the audience
I don't believe me parentally and just
like that the unlikely marriage of
Hendrix and the monkeys had come to an
end
Jimi of course went on to be well Jimi
Hendrix possibly the greatest rock and
roll guitarist ever as far as I'm
concerned I'd like to think that we
might have had something to do with it
but I think he would have done okay
without opening for the Monkees
[Music]
imagine remembering every single day of
your life all in perfect detail for
those with highly superior
autobiographical memory or h Sam for
short this is their reality
I remember everything that's personally
happened to me since I was born that's
Rebecca sharukh I was fascinated by this
condition so I called her up to find out
more hi Rebecca
hi how are you going I'm doing all right
it's a very wet Saturday morning here
how are you going sidenote in this
moment I just realized Rebecca will
remember that this day was a wet morning
forever so you remember everything in
great detail people can remember what
they did last Saturday but I can
remember what I did Saturday ten years
ago what about a memory from when you
uttered the baby when I was 12 days old
I was lying down on the fur car seat in
my parents car and I was staring up at
the steering wheel and I thought what is
that Rebecca is one of only 60 people
worldwide to have been identified with
having hate sale all through my teenage
years I thought that everybody
remembered in this kind of way I thought
it was completely normal it wasn't until
she was 21
when her parents decided to submit her
to the University of California to
undergo two years of testing after this
she was officially identified as having
H Sam since memories can come to mind
unexpectedly any time of day a negative
memory like this can make living with
HCM difficult
mum was porting me in
this it she satin dress and I was crying
because I didn't like it and mum gave me
this Minnie Mouse toy and I couldn't say
anything at the time but her face
terrified me but on most days eh Sam as
a gift
Rebecca can recall happy memories and
moments when times get tough but good
memory it makes me so thank all about
having this kind of pace and memory
thanks for chatting Rebecca yep
[Music]
in 1904 st. Louis hosted an Olympic
marathon for the ages overshadowed by
the neighboring World's Fair the poorly
planned event was reduced to a
lackluster sideshow primed for disaster
during a sweltering 90 degree day the
runners were thrust onto a hellish route
that cut through car traffic rocks thick
dust and 300-foot hills of the 32
athletes who competed only 14 finished
and of the 14 these are the three worth
knowing about
Fred lorz was a fresh-faced athlete
ready to make a name for himself for
nine miles lures was near the front of
the pack
until painful muscle cramps stopped him
in his tracks Yanks and he wasn't the
only one almost every single racer had
severe muscle cramps that day thanks to
this dummy chief event organizer and
amateur scientist James Sullivan UC
Sullivan turned the event into an
experiment to grasp how purposeful
dehydration affects athletes immune to
common sense
Sullivan put a single water station at
the 11th mile mark so for 26 miles
the runners relied on one water station
that was dirty and gave you dysentery
James Sullivan what a guy boobs anyway
back to lures with the Sun beating down
road dusk clogging his lungs and his
muscles spazzing in protest
Laura's had enough and traded in his two
legs for four wheels he hitched a car
ride to the 19th mile mark got out and
gingerly ran through the finish line the
crowd went wild but before the gold
medal could be placed around his neck
his bruise was discovered next up and
the rim Carbajal he was a 5-foot tall
Cuban national and former mailman turned
athlete to get to st. Louis Carbajal had
to raise money by competing and running
events including a 700 mile race across
Cuba once he got to st. Louis he was
easy to spot among the sleeveless shirts
and thigh-highs shorts Carbajal wore a
billowing long-sleeve shirt cut off
slacks and work boots he didn't dress
like a sports champion but damn did he
run like one
[Music]
with each and every step carbajal
charged towards the finish line
even though his legs never gave out his
grumbling stomach peeled to satisfy his
hunger he ate some apples from a nearby
orchard that turned out to be rotten so
he took a little recovery nap and then
proceeded to finish in fourth place and
then there's Thomas Hicks the gold
winner the top dog the champion the
barely standing living cadaver you see
Hicks was so physically ill that he
couldn't cross the finish line without
the help of his trainers why well back
then stimulants were legal and
strychnine a type of rat poison was
thought to have performance-enhancing
properties so during the run his
trainers gave him small doses to gain an
edge but instead of helping him it was
slowly killing him once Hicks was
dragged across the finish line he wasn't
in a cheery mood having lost eight
pounds during the race he was a
hollowed-out husk of a man the judges
shrugged who gave Hicks the gold ending
the nightmare as the crowd swooned over
Hicks disheveled body somewhere in the
stands James Sullivan was probably
sipping on a glass of fresh water
feeling proud of putting together the
worst marathon ever
[Music]